-Welcome back.
We're hanging out with Florence
Pugh, ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, Florence, we love getting
to know our guests
here at "The Tonight Show"
and I thought it would be fun
to do it while playing a game.
It's time to play "Guest Test."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show guest test,
yeah ♪
-Here's how it works.
Before the show, you answered
a series of questions about
things that you like.
-Yep.
-And now the audience is
going to try
to guess your answers.
Everyone has clickers
at their seats.
So, you can vote answers A or B.
Okay, we're going to do
five questions.
And here's the deal.
If our audience gets at least
three questions right,
everyone gets a free pint of
Tonight Dough Ben and Jerry's
ice cream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, yeah, you guys --
-I'm sorry if it doesn't
work out your way, guys, because
that's a good prize.
-Yeah, people are going to be
really disappointed, yeah.
Because it was going so well.
-I know.
-The interview was great.
We loved you.
We gave you a standing ovation.
Now, who knows
what's going to happen.
-They're going to throw
ice cream at me.
-"We want ice cream."
Alright, here we go.
This first question --
I don't know the answers either,
so I'm not --
these aren't rigged.
What is your favorite '90s song?
Is it, A, "Blue (Da Ba Dee),"
Eiffel 65.
♪ I'm blue, da ba dee
da bu die ♪
Okay.
Or is it "Barbie Girl" by Aqua?
♪ I'm a Barbie girl ♪
[ Humming ]
Hmm. I'm going to vote too.
Quest, you're voting too?
Tariq, you're voting?
What do you think it is?
I think I'm going to say it's
"Blue (Da Ba Dee)."
-Are we talking about my fave?
-No, we're picking Florence's.
-Yeah, sure, your favorite.
-Florence's favorite.
-Ah. I got to go with my own.
I'm "Barbie Girl" all day.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Let's see the audience results.
The audience chose...
"Barbie Girl."
Uh-oh. Florence, tell us
what is your favorite song
from the '90s.
-It's "Blue."
[ Sad tuba ]
Hang on, there's a reason.
-Why?
-I'm 10 years younger than my
older sister, and when that was
happening, my older sister
was playing it all the time.
And I thought this was,
like, the disco tune.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so I'd walk past her room
and I'm like...
[ Humming ]
[ Laughter ]
And so, that's just been
in my head.
-Alright, alright.
We're 0 for 1 for audience, but
we are getting to know you.
-Yes.
-Yeah, which I love.
-Most important thing.
-That's the important, yeah.
Just to know each other.
That's all we really want.
More than ice cream.
It's friendship.
[ Laughter ]
What is your favorite
Florence Pugh movie?
This is a tricky question
to ask you.
-Yeah, this was a weird one
because I don't watch
my own movies,
like, on the regular.
I'm not like,
"Ooh, it's Friday night.
I'll watch my own movie."
-Is it "Midsommar"
or is it "Lady Macbeth"?
-It's a hard one. This is
a weird question as well.
-Yeah, this is a tricky one
for me.
I mean --
-Stumped?
-Yeah, I'm going to say
"Midsommar."
I'm going to say,
A, "Midsommar."
Tariq, what are you thinking
on this?
-I'm going to go, you know, just
because you said, "Midsommar,"
I'm going to go "Lady Macbeth."
[ Laughter ]
-You going to go the opposite?
-Yeah, man.
-Crowd, are you leaning one way
or the other?
[ Audience says "Midsommar" ]
-"Midsommar."
The audience is saying
"Midsommar."
What are we saying right here?
Audience, what do you think?
[ Audience shouting ]
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-It's very, very close.
-You were so close!
It's "Lady Macbeth"!
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-Are you doing it on purpose?
Are you doing it on purpose?
-Hang on, hang on, hang on.
Okay.
The question was, which one --
I didn't understand what it was.
Like, do I want to watch them
or did I enjoy being in them?
And because it was such a weird,
small-budget movie
and I appreciated what it did
for me and my career,
I chose "Lady Macbeth,"
but now I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here's the thing.
So, we have two -- alright,
we need to get these next
three completely right.
-Yeah, guys.
-If the audience is going to go
home with ice cream tonight.
We've got to really focus up,
guys!
[ Cheers ]
Think. We are Florence Pugh.
We are in Florence's brain.
Ready?
What is your favorite color?
[ Laughter ]
Is it, A, rusty orange?
Or is it, B, sky blue?
I think -- I'm going to say
rusty orange.
I'm feeling -- Florence, I think
sky blue is too common for you.
-Yeah, it's a bit --
it's -- I don't know.
I'm not saying anything.
-Yeah, okay.
But you almost said something.
-I did, and I'm so sorry.
-Guys, did you --
alright, did you hear that?
Are you paying attention?
-I said nothing.
-Alright, I'm going to say
rusty orange.
Let's see the results.
Audience, what is Florence's
favorite color?
Rusty orange?
-No!
-Is the answer?
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We want to get ice cream.
Alright.
-We got one.
-I do love rusty orange.
-Me too, especially when it's
actual rust.
-Ooh, yeah.
-Yeah, and you shouldn't touch
it because you might get
ill and die.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
The dangerous color.
Yeah, exactly.
I want my colors
to be dangerous.
Alright. Here we go.
-Fiery red.
-Yes, ooh!
What is your favorite way
to relax?
Is it, A, a massage
and then audio book?
Or is it, B, a bath
and "Real Housewives"?
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, you -- it says bath
and "Real Housewives."
I think massage and audio book
is not --
Your favorite way to relax?
A bath and "Real Housewives" is
unbelievable.
If you really watch "Real
Housewives," it is relaxing.
I'm going to say it's --
[ Laughter ]
I do. I love it.
Because you know what?
I go, "It's not my problem."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I don't have to deal with that.
-I don't have to deal with that.
That's none of my business.
And that's why I love it, so I'm
going to go B on this one.
Tariq, what do you think?
-Dude, definitely
massage and audio book.
-Massage and audio book?
It sounds like you're doing
too many things at once.
Pressing play and pause.
Loud, up, harder, softer.
Too much involved.
Bath and "Real Housewives,"
what do you guys think?
Audience, let's see the results.
[ Audience shouts B ]
Bath and "Real Housewives"?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One more to go! One more to go!
-You're so right though.
[ Laughter ]
It really is so relaxing knowing
that you don't have to
deal with that or this.
-No. It's none of my business.
-None of my business.
But I can sit in the bath
and drink my wine
and go mwah!
-I love that.
Alright. This is the last one.
This is for Ben and Jerry's
ice cream
for everyone in the audience.
[ Cheers ]
Ooh!
-[ Laughs ]
You're kneeling on your chair.
-I'm excited.
I'm freaking out.
This is, like, a big deal.
Do you know how many people
would be happy
if they get this right?
[ Cheers ]
-Yeah, and you'll now
really know me.
-And I feel like --
Already I feel like I know you.
But here we go. What is
your favorite pizza topping?
-Oh.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh, no.
-But this is tricky because
you're from England.
-Yeah.
Well, what?
That doesn't mean anything.
[ Laughter ]
I still have taste.
-I know, but there's
different rules there.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I see.
-Is it, A -- it can't be this.
[ Laughter ]
A, ham and pineapple.
Or, B, sausage and mushrooms.
Ooh, silence.
'Cause I've been to England
a bunch of times.
And I feel like
ham and pineapple
are, like, Americanized.
They brought that over there
and people got used to it.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's think sausage.
[ English accent ] 'Ello.
Say it. Sausage.
Sausage. That's how they say it.
[ Laughter ]
Sausage.
You don't say ham and pineapple.
You go sausage.
'Ey! Oi!
-Oi!
-Oi, sausage.
[ Normal voice ]
You yell at people.
You get it. [English accent]
'Ey, sausage and mushroom!
Yell it!
[Normal voice] I think it is --
-Are you using your tongue
when you speak or not?
-No. Not at all.
[ English accent ]
It's sausage and mushroom!
[ Normal voice ]
And you yell it at people.
Guys, I think --
What are we thinking here?
[ Audience shouts B ]
We got to vote. Come on.
I want ice cream so bad.
Let's see the results.
Sausage and mushroom.
-Yes!
-Is that correct?
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Ice cream!
Come on!
Sausage and mushroom!
Ice cream for everybody!
Tonight Dough and Florence Pugh!
"A Good Person" hits theaters
this Friday!
We'll be right back
with Gaten Matarazzo.
Stick around, everybody.